[Captioner standing by for
presentation to begin.
]
to good afternoon
.
>> It's the second in our
ongoing PTSD
panel series in collaboration
with the National Institute of
Corrections
civilian life I'd like to
welcome the
-- it is the work they do that
makes these types of discussions
possible and so valuable.
As an Army veteran, I know how
untreated PTSD can affect a
veterans life.
Our partners at the National
Institute of Corrections know
all too well how
PTSD can create problems with
reentry into society and how it
can lead to run-ins with the law
and entry into the justice and
prison systems.
But as you learn today, it
doesn't have to be this way.  We
have pulled together several
experts who have seen first hand
how
treating PTSD and adding
structure to a
veteran inmate's lives in the
veterans inmates housing units
with break the cycle of crime
and recidivism.  This panel
represents another example of
how the Veterans History Project
is working to illuminate the
work done by a wide variety of
organizations that focus on
assisting our veterans to move
forward with their lives and
further enrich their life
stories, which we
certainly hope they then choose
to
donate to the library so others
could learn from their
experiences.
Our next speaker is Frank Laura
of the U.S.
bureau of  prisons.
He's the veterans of the U.S.
Marine Corps and is with the
correctional programs division.
He began his career as a
correctional officer in
Segalville Texas where he rose
through the ranks, eventually
being named warden at the
federal correctional
complex Bomont where he received
the new
warden of the year award from
the bureau of prisons.
In prisons, he became the
assistant
director of the correctional
programs division.
Please, help me welcome
assistant director Laura.
>> Good afternoon. Thank you,
Karen, for the introduction.
I'm honored to be here.
The director couldn't make it
and he had unplanned activities
that were on his calendar that
showed up.  He regrets not being
here.
I did tell him this: You're
sending a corporal.  That's
equivalent to a general in the
Army.  He took that pretty good.
[Laughter]
As Karen mentioned I served the
bureau
of prison for 26 years in
various capacities.
I've moved capacity times.
I've worked two times at --
prior to
joining the federal bureau of
prison I proudly served the
Marine Corps and
existed the and existed a
corporal.
I'm here on behalf of the
federal bureau of prisons and
the staff and the
facilities nationwide.
And Army corrections command
where he maintained executive
management oversight of the Army
corrections system.
Regardless of when or where they
served, or for how long, gave of
themselves to ensure that all
Americans continued to
ensure the freedoms and
opportunities, the foundation of
this country.
I know first hand, some of the
challenges veterans face as a
result of spending time in
places and
circumstances many cannot even
imagine.
We are here today to increase
the awareness about PTSD.
post-traumatic stress syndrome.
Some of this men and women
struggle to adapt back into
society after having served
therefore country.
Post-traumatic stress syndrome
can
also contribute to their
involvement in the justice
system.
Approximately 7% of 200,000 of
the people incarcerated in our
nations jails and prisons are
men and women who have
served in the armied armed
forces.
A significant portion of the
combat
troops are returning home
affected by visible and
invisible battle scars
including high rates of PTSD and
traumatic brain injury, as well
as serious wounds.
Some veterans return home and
struggle and find themselves
using substances and others
struggle with various forms of
mental illness related to their
deployments.
All these issues may in some
cases
lead
to the justice system
involvement and incarcerations.
Various housing units promotes
opportunities to assist veterans
in preparation to return to our
communities with skills and
confidence to be productive and
contributing members of society.
The bureau of prison houses
nearly 11,000 veterans
nationwide across our 22
falsities
nationwide facilities.
We have devoted to meeting the
needs of groups of inmates with
specialized needs.
We have a wide variety of
services for veteran inmates,
but we are in the
process of standardizing
services nationwide.
We developed a three-tiered
services delivery model.
Tier one delivery has just begun
to be rolled out nationwide.
These are primarily these
service in nature.  They
conclude training, best
practices, guidance for staff,
and forms and resources
available to the inmate
population.
Each facility will collaborate
with veterans administration
staff to ensure
inmate veterans and families of
inmates
of veterans have access to the
information they need.
Tier two will be rolled out
later this year.  These are
outpatient services.  These will
be delivered in a group model
including a veteran support
group
and veterans fitness vet.
Tier three will be the most
intense in nature and include
the piloting of a
unit- piloting based residential
program.  We look forward to
collaborating with many of you
as we roll out these services
nationwide.
Today, it is my honor and
pleasure to announce the
National Institute of
Corrections publication entitled
Barrack Behind Bar Bars veterans
help veterans help themselves.
This publication tells the story
of both
forward thinking sheriffs who
have instituted veterans housing
units in their jails and some on
of the veterans who have
benefited from these programs.
We've seen a number of these
housing
units or dorms or pods for
veterans implemented throughout
the country.
This is designed to serve as a
resource throughout the field as
they consider veteran
programming.
Another thing is the sequential
intercept model adapted to the
justice involved veteran
population.
As you can see, each decision
point provides resources and
represents an opportunity to
intervene at the lowest
level possible to minimize the
co
consequences of a veteran
getting more deeply involved in
the justice system.
Today, you'll hear some from
folks included in the
publication, including
our next speaker, Peter
Koutoujian, from middle
from  Middlesex county,
Massachusetts.
It's the largest county in
Massachusetts, and if I'm not
mistaken,
all of New England.
He aims to increase politic
confidence, providing a safer
work environment for staff, and
improving the lives of those in
the county's custody.
Including in 2016 the creation
of the Humvee program, a housing
unit for military veterans.
Ladies and gentlemen, sheriff
Peter Koutoujian.
[Applause]
>> PETER KOUTOUJIAN: Good
afternoon.  Good afternoon.
>> Good afternoon.
Peter  Peter
>> PETER KOUTOUJIAN: I want to
thank director Lloyd and the
Library of Congress.  This is
truly an amazing building that I
know is not nearly as
appreciated as it should be.  I
appreciate it to a much larger
degree now.  I thank you for
hosting today's event.
To Steven and Amos and from the
National Institute of
Corrections, team his team at
Corrections help agencies like
mine to increase our knowledge
and support and to sheriffs
across the country.
And for assistant director
Laura.  Thank you for that
introduction.  I know you were
afraid of my name and you did
very well.  Thank you very much
for that, sir.
I'm truly honored to be here
among such a distinguished group
of leaders from across the
country.
From Cuyahoga County, to Orange
County, in Ohio, New York,
Texas, and elsewhere.
On behalf of all of us here and
my Middlesex county office, to
all who
serveed our country, I say thank
you for your service.
I did not serve in the military.
My family has a history of
service that has always impacted
me.
My family came here to flee
genocide.  They sought refuge
and opportunity in this country,
and they found it.
Three of their sons war the
uniform uniform.
My uncle Arson who died in an
accident
while serving in the Philippines
at the age of 19.
My grandmother who could barely
speak English, was, for all
intents and
purposes, a gold star mother in
the loss of her young son.
Yet, my grandparents loveed this
country and everything it
afforded us, the truest of
patriots.
And if I can just take a moment
of how proud they would be to
know that their grandson is
speaking at the Library of
Congress, as well.  Right?
It was that appreciation of
service that wanted me to do
better for incarcerated
veterans.
After becoming sheriff in 2011 I
discovered we were lacking in
verifyied demographic
information on veterans.  At the
time, the only way we knew if
someone was a veteran, if they
told us
they were a told
veteran.
We didn't know the scope of this
problem because we didn't have
verified numbers anywhere across
this country.
This is incredibly ineffective
because
we knew we would miss folks
because sometimes as they were
coming close to
release they would let us now,
but by then it was too late to
give them the proper supports
they needed.
We later learned that many were
not identifying themselves is
because they were afraid of
losing benefits.
Some didn't know they were
qualified
as others, or there was a stigma
of shame for having been in a
place of incarceration.
I knew there was a lot more we
could be doing to improve the
lives of these individuals, and
their families, and their
families.  It was then we
started speaking to the VA about
how we could better identify
veterans and it began with a
launch of
the VRSS, developed by the VA,
that
allowed us to match the list of
those in our custody against
federal databases.
On day one we had 19 men who had
self-identified as having served
this country.
VRSS immediately told us that
number was wrong.
We had another 44 in our custody
we didn't know about.
In fact, two-thirds more than we
knew about were serving time
with us.
We had tripled the number of
veterans in our custody.
That's why VRSS is a critical
tool
that should be utilized by every
facility across this country.
So designed in collaboration
with administrators and staff
and the
incarcerated themselves, it was
opened
in themselves and named by the
veterans themselves.
Ours is not the first and not
the last
unit designed for veterans
suffering
from so many ailments, including
post-traumatic stress syndrome.
Sheriffs from all over recognize
specially tailored programming
for targeted population works.
A unique population, unique
solution, unique results.
Veterans units, particularly,
work so much more effectively
for a number of reasons.  One
because of the staffs and the
officers, the volunteers and the
programmatic staff specially
trained to work with veterans.
There are community resources
that can transition to
postrelease to continue their
treatment, including the VA and
many non-profits.  And most
importantly because of the
veterans themselves public,
their own drive, their own
change.
In Middlesex we found the sample
act of opening the doors opened
opportunities for rehad been  .
The men in the Humvee said being
out of the general population
allowed them to let their guard
down and showed them they were
not aalone, because they felt
to alone before, and led them to
open up about their trauma while
in incarceration.
They said it was very much like
being in the service.  Where in
other parts of the facility, you
had to watch your back.  In this
unit, you knew you had someone
at your back and you had someone
on your left and someone on your
right and all
you needed to do was look
forward.
In our unit, it didn't matter
whether you served in Vietnam or
enduring freedom.  Whether you
spent a year on a
submarine, involved in combat or
served state-side or discharged
Honorably or not.  In some
instances, the issues that led
to a less than Honorable
discharge are the very same
reasons that led to their
incarceration, as well.
If you swore an oath and were
willing to protect our freedom,
we will consider you for our
freedom.
Our experience is not much
different than our colleagues
around the nation, many of whom
are here today and spoke with
such passion and knowledge and
expertise.
The work is changing lives and
changes families and changing
communities and
making our communities safer and
saving our communities money all
at the same time.
You can see in the data.
Our own snap shot pegged our
recidivism at just 5% over two
and a half years.  Two%.
Not only that about we have a
parol rate of about 95%.
Sentences were actually lessened
by the courts themselves.
We had a number of men able to
remain
in our unit instead of going to
the state prison system because
of the work
we had done with them in the
belief in us by the court
program.
That's consistent with other
programs
like Albany and an San Francisco
who
have also reported single-digit
recidivism rates.
You can see it in the stories
and hear
it in the voices of the veterans
themselves, like Mike, who was
able to get out much earlier.
I was walking at a Labor Day
parade, waving at the people at
the sides of the parade.
Suddenly as I walked by one
corner on the section up on the
hill I heard someone yell out,
"Humvee." I looked over and saw
a man sitting
there with a woman giving me a
thumb's up.
I ran up and he was doing
fabulously well.  We had allowed
him this opportunity.
And John who was two inches
short of
killing himself with a short
gun.  He said if he had another
two inches in his arm, we would
have been dead.  He came to our
facility and at one
point was free to leave on a
parol to a bed parol was
providing for him, but the
bed we were going to provide him
through veterans affairs was not
going to be available for
another month.
By  God, he stayed with us for
another month in a place of
incarceration
because he knew we had a bed for
him
following and we had a bed for
following that for treatment
with his PTSD.
There are ideas about veterans
units popping up around the
country.
Mark Lamp is a border sheriff
and a
true cow
boy, and he had a "it's kind of
funny because we're like the odd
couple.
He's a democrat liberal from
Massachusetts -- I'm not sure
that's
meant in the most fond way --
and I'm a conservative sheriff
from Arizona, but it shows how
we work together in this
country.  With these initiatives
that show that veterans, while
they're being held
accountable for those actions,
we also honor their services.
And as it is said in the
branches of
the military, we leave no man
behind.
We show them we won't leave them
behind."
It's my honor to introduce James
Wright.  I'll speak from a
summary of his
summarized summary, because his
accomplishments are so
significant.
He joined the Marine Corps in
1957.  He became his first
member of the family to graduate
from college.
He went on to earn a  Ph.D.
in history and joined the
faculty in Dartmouth College.
He served as the president of
Dartmouth.
For the last 14 years he's been
working to support veterans.
He's been recognized by the
Army, the
Marine Corps, the the veterans
or foreign wars.
He's also returned to his work
publishing books of those who
have
served, and those who fought
wars.
It is my great honor to
introduce James Wright.
[Applause]
introduce.
>> JAMES WRIGHT: Thank you,
sheriff.  You're very kind.  I
certainly want to add on behalf
of everyone in this room a
salute to you for your own
creative and effective
leadership and in support of
veterans.
It's really quite improve what
you've
done in Middlesex county.
I'm pleased to be here in join
Karen Lloyd and Frank Lara on
this program.  I thank them for
their service and for their
continuing work on behalf of
veterans.
I applaud the commitment of the
bureau of prisons and the
National Institute of
Corrections to veterans issues
and I
commend the report that Bernard
Edelman
of Vietnam Veterans of America,
and that organization's veterans
committee have done.  I look
forward to the panel, chaired
by Jonathan Elias, with this
special commitment to telling
the stories of veterans.
It is an impressive group of
panelists.
group who daily engage and work
to resolve these issues.
My special thanks to Bernard
Edelman and Greg Crawford for
their service and lifetime
commitment to serving those who
have served.  They have made a
difference and
they're not yet finished making
a difference.
Greg, thank you for all you've
done to help organize and pull
together this program.
I also want to acknowledge our
hosts
here today, the Library of
Congress, my
personal thanks to Karen Lloyd
and the Veterans History
Project.  This is a very
important program.
In my book Enduring Vietnam, I
acknowledge how valuable they
were in
providing personal experiences
that
enrich my account of those who
had fought in Vietnam.
Special thanks to Megan Harris
of this project for all of her
help.
Let me do a brief personal
account, because I think some
parts of it are relevant to the
subject that we're engaged in
today.
In the summer of.
of 2005, I made my first visit
to Bethesda navel hospital.
The
previous November I had been
very moved
and troubled by the battle of
Fallujah and Iraq.  These were
the same age of people that I
was when I was in the Marines.
These were the same age as the
students where I worked at
Dartmouth.
Indeed, a son of a friend of
ours had
been killed, a marine, in
Fallujah.
I thought I wanted to reach out
in some
bay way to those who were
serving.  A friend said why
don't you go down to the
Bethesda hospital and visit with
the marines there?  And I did.
Since then, I've been to
Bethesda Walter reed over 30
times to visit with veterans.  I
haven't been there for a few
years.  There are not as many.
The wounded veterans pipeline
has slowed significantly.
Whether I would go to the
hospital, my pattern was always
the same.
I would go bed-to-bed and ask
the patient what happened.
And you know, I never once
encountered
anyone -- and those of you who
know Walter Reed know these were
the most seriously injured and
wounded, in most cases.
I never had anyone balk at
telling me what had happened.
Then I would engage them about a
conversation about their future
and what they hoped to do.
I kept reminding them you have a
great future ahead of you; let's
think about what you might do.
I would ask them by their own
educational background and plans
and I would try to encourage
them to continue their
education.
I assured them that they'd
already demonstrated their
discipline, their
commitment to serveing, and now
they needed to prepare
themselves for the rest of their
lives.
They still had so much to do, so
much more that they could
contribute.
I was able to set up an
educational
counseling program with the
American
Council on Education at Walter
Reed Bethesda and I went out and
raised the money to get it
started, and nearly 12 years
later it is still in place at
Walter Reed, now under the
semper phi funds
organizationally.
A few years after that, I was
able to
work with senators Jim Webb and
Jon
Warner and Chuck Hagel on the
post 9/the
9/11 GI bill.
I encouraged them to include
what ended up being called the
yellow ribbon program because it
gave the opportunity for private
schools to contribute money of
their own to match that of the
VA to make sure that private
schools were an option for these
veterans.
And last year, the congress,
with
bipartisanship improved an
extension and expansion of that
legislation.
It's important and I think
everyone needs to know and
recognize that legislation such
as this, legislation
such as the GI bill, this is not
a thank
you for your service
gratuity.  It may provide an
incentive to serve.  That would
be good.
It may provide immediately a
fully
deserved acknowledgment of adone
so, enabling veterans back into
their transition into the
civilian life.  Civilian also an
investment into the future of
this republic.
What a resource these veterans
can provide if we can enable
them and provide them the
opportunity to pursue it.
The ranks of the American
military today are filled with
volunteers.
They do not represent the nation
demographically.
They tend to be more rural than
urban.
More heartland than coastal.
They're largely from blue collar
middle class backgrounds, and
they tend disproportionately to
come from military families.
They constitute less than 1% of
the population.  These 21st
Century wars are the first
extended wars in American
history, with
no designated tax to help pay
for the wars.
And no service requirement for
citizens of this country.
So much for George Washington's
reminder that it is necessary to
go -- if it is
necessary to go to war, all
citizens
should support this with their
treasure and with their service.
Not anymore.  Not for these
wars.
These veterans can come home and
spend a good part of the rest of
their lives helping to pay off
the debt of the wars in which
they fought.  And the vast
majority of us go on with our
lives.
Those who serve in the 21st
century wars
are the best educated of
Americans to serve in any war.
They are better educated than
their age group as a whole.  The
armed forces expect at least a
high school education.
And that's a good positive step.
But you know, we all know,
unfortunately, a high school
education
is insufficient in this modern
economy.
The recent pattern of veterans
having higher unemployment rates
than nonveterans has been
largely the result of their
educational background rather
than a negative judgment on
their military service.
The parents and the grandparents
of the
current veterans came home from
World
War II, Korea, Vietnam, and if
they did
not use the GI bill to pursue
education,
they could pretty much count on
getting some good jobs at a
local factory, a mill, or a
mine.
And they could really count on
knowing
that if they worked hard, they
could probably have that job
until they retired.
And then when we did retire,
they
would have some pension plan to
help them.
Let's face it.  Those
opportunities are far more
limited today and there's far
less likelihood of that lifetime
security.
The post 9/11 GI bill offers
them an opportunity to set a
course for their future.  But,
you know, I learned early on in
my conversations that while it
is essential to provide the
financial
support for veterans to continue
their
education, there was a prior and
often more difficult counseling
need.
This was to encourage them to do
this,
to assure them that they could
do this.
While nearly all of those who
have
joined the all volunteer
military may be high school
graduates, most of them did not
take college preparatory
courses.  They probably have not
taken
standardized ACT or SAT exams.
They often feel unprepared for
higher
education, and some of them may
not be ready.
But I have no doubt, I have no
doubt, that they all can be
ready.
Counseling and convincing them
of this is essential.  As is
follow-up support to encourage
them to pursue and to succeed.
You see, we have a national
need, an obligation, to try to
encourage all
students who have never been
encouraged.  They can do this.
And this is where those young
men and
women with military experience
can draw on some greater
self-confidence if we
can remind them why they should
have
this greater
they should confidence.
There's another part of military
experience that we need to
understand.
All of the children in this
country
really, human beings across the
world,
learn as infants to remember two
pretty constant things.
One is to look out for
themselves.
Avoid any threatening risks.
Don't go there.  Don't touch
that.  Look carefully.  Because
cautious.
And they are also told not to
harm others.
And the latter is more than
parentsal guidance as it's
emphasized under threat
of law, as well as moral code
and religious teachings.  Do not
bring harm to other people.
Think of it, a very small
fraction of our citizens in
their late teens and
early 20s when they're mobilized
for war, they are told they have
to suppress
these fundamental instincts and
principles when the situation
demands.
They must be willing to put
themselves in harm's way without
question or without hesitation.
Go there and do it.  They go and
do.
They don't stop and reflect on
it." This looks dangerous."
That's not their job.  They're
told to go.
And they must be willing to
bring harm to others.  Lethal
harm.
Without any delay, any
opportunity for
moral reflection  "should I be
doing this?" This is their
assignment.
Now, when they return to
civilian life they're told to
return
to their first rules: To forget
that
which they just learned and to
wipe from their memory contrary
experiences.  Obviously, in each
of these instances, this is
impossible.
The vast majority of combat
veterans do return to civilian
lives
successfully, but they never
forget that experience that they
had.
It is a difficult transition.
Some do not return as
successfully as others.
And indeed, some of this group
are a
matter for our focus today.
We need to know the experience
of war from those who are there
before we can begin to
understand it.  To know how
profound this experience
is, how contrary it is, to
everything
they've been taught and learned.
As a Vietnam veteran, Army
combat
photographer, a friend, Victor
Ants recently described it, they
risked their lives.
They faced terror.  They lose
buddies in battles.  And then
they come home, where they
had to square what they had to
do with
warriors with now what they're
expected to do now that they're
home.  It isn't easy.
Veterans who are in prison for
committing a crime face many of
the same
problems that in which veterans
face
nonveterans face in
transitioning back to civilian
life after release.
Problems with acceptance and
employment andians enters
society while encountering
suspicion at every turn.
And finally of avoiding
recidivism.
This path is harder to avoid if
individuals encounter a society
that has little confidence in a
good outcome.  These problems
may be compounded for veterans
who have been released.
They confront dual and
reinforcing stereotypes.
The current "ban the box"
initiative to
encourage respective employers
and
admoni
into discontinue asking criminal
history, is an interesting
effort.
It's reminiscence of the Vietnam
veterans in the 1970s who didn't
acknowledge their military
service on job applications,
because they thought this was
something that would be far
better for them if their
employer didn't
have to say, "Were you a
veteran?
" And ask some of the most
foolish questions you could
imagine.
We've come a great distance
medically since post-traumatic
stress syndrome was
recorded recognized as a
clinical disorder.
But that journey is not over.
And the distance remains even
greater in accomplishing social
acceptance of this mental health
condition.
The mental -- the medical and
the legal recognition of
post-traumatic stress syndrome
has been so important.  We
discuss it more openly now.
But you know, I also worry that
this
talking about it more openly,
ironically, has buttressed
another cruel stereotype.
That of the socially unhinged
veteran.
The Vietnam veterans in the
1970s came straight in to this
headwind.
And they encountered movies such
as
Taxi Driver and Apocalypse Now,
which
deranged psychotic veterans
emerged.
The 1970s were not kind to
veterans coming back from an
unpopular war.
From the early in the 70s on the
television show Kojak,  Teli
Savalas confronted a group of
homicides in Manhattan.
He told one of his colleagues to
find
out if there were any Vietnam
veterans in the neighborhood of
the crime.  Think of this.  Are
there any Vietnam veterans
there?
Post-traumatic stress syndrome
is a companion of all wars.
Read Odysses.
But this was not even diagnosed
as a clinical condition until
1979.  Before that, they were
categorized as suffering from
the Vietnam syndrome, as
if it were an isolated condition
of what so many other veterans
thought of as
this wind
whining hippie group coming back
from Vietnam.
Their parents generation told
them to grow up and get over
it.  They said, "We did.  "
But, of course, not all of them
did.
It was called combat fatigue or
shell shock then.
The Vietnam veterans spoke of
nightmares becoming daymares.
One said to me if those other
people
had to spend just one night
inside my nightmares, they would
fall to the floor with tears in
their eyes.
But these veterans endured and
they have
contributed so much to our
national life.  One thing we've
learned is that
veterans will speak about their
experiences more candidly and
more personally with other
veterans.
Some of the best counseling
sessions involve a group of
veterans sharing
their stories and encouraging
one another.
If post 9/11 veterans have not
had to contend with the same
nasty degrading
stereotypes in popular culture,
they still have often to
encounter wisps of
the fear and prejudice that
remain.
And here their reinforcing fear
and prejudice and suspicion that
confronts
the ones who are former convicts
and veterans can be even harder
to escape.
If this is their difficult
assignment, I have confidence in
them.  But our society has a
role, as well.
We still need to thank them for
their
service and recognize this as
not a
condescending throw-away
gratuity.
They need a hand, not a hand
out.  They need a hand.  We need
to recognize what they've done
on our behalf, even if they have
stumbled since.  They have much
to offer.  Americans today to
juggle their views of the
current generation of veterans.
They applaud them when they're
introduced at events.
They call them all heroes.
Yet, they're also a little bit
uneasy around them sometimes.
We all need to know them better.
We need to understand who they
are,
what they've endured, what they
want to do.  These veterans have
worked effectively
with others of different
backgrounds.
They have assumed responsibility
and accountability.  They've
functioned in complex
organizations in an advanced
technological environment.
And they've confronted dangerous
situations while respecting
people of different cultures.
They have learned discipline and
restraint and self-confidence
and tolerance.  They have
observed and they have
themselves offered sacrifice for
a greater good.
I'm impressed by the options
that sheriffs and wardens such
as those
speaking here today, officers
such as
Sheriff Peter Koutoujian and his
Middlesex county middlecaptain
Malik
Muhammad of Orange County
Florida, and Ron Perez
, and judge Michael Jackson.
Semper phi, judge, and thank you
for what you've done.
Their counseling and the
specialized living units that
some have developed
allow veterans to connect with
each other.
Remember, they are more
comfortable talking to each
other.
It's an essential step towards
their reconnecting with society,
with that society that sent them
to war.
The report, which is released
today, in
this gathering, addressed the
value of the programs such as
these.  These veterans have met
their obligation.  Now, we have
an obligation.  To reach out to
them.
They will benefit from our
support, of course.
As we all have already greatly
benefited from all that they
have done.
And we and our society will be
the
better if we are able to help
them to succeed.  It is truly a
win-win.
We are all ahead if we can help
them to succeed.
Maybe it's too much delayed, but
now we need to say in a delayed
reciprocal, we've got your back,
now.  We want to help you.
I'm going to hand off the stage
to our moderator, Jonathan
Elias.  Mr.
Elias is an award winning
journalist
and the host of WJLA-TV's Salute
to Veterans.
To an instructor at the Army War
College and he's passionate
about veterans issues.  Before
that, I believe we have a brief
video message from an attorney
at the
Harvard law school veterans law
and disability benefits office.
Thank you for participating in
this program today.
[Applause]
[Video plays.
]
>> Good afternoon. That's all
you got, really?
We need a  7th inning stretch
around here.
I became involved with the
military two decades ago now.
I was early on recognizing
purple heart recipients.
I knew a lot of friends of mine
who
were veterans and maybe their
bodies were bruised but their
spirits were intact.
He  I wanted to celebrate that
spirit.  We used to have
gatherings of strangers to come
together to say thank you very
much for your service and
welcome home.
I had someone come up to me, a
good
looking kid, and he said, "Why
are you doing this?"
And he started to cry and I just
sat there and held this kid and
we talked for a while.  He asked
me again, why are you doing
this?  I said, well, because
everybody should.  Then it got
me introduced to the whole idea
of what PTSD, this window
dressing
of this button down good looking
kid was a veneer to something
more painful and more deep.
When I spent time talking he
explained to me war is its own
language.
Approximatethe language of war
is one where there is pain.
When you're having a bad day,
maybe the boss didn't like
something you did.
When they have a bad day, they
stop on something that goes boom
and their lives are forever
changed because they're losing
their legs or arms or ability to
do anything.
Their language of war is so
impossible for us to speak.
If you've not walked or marched
in a battlefield with brothers
and sisters to your side and
suffered the loss of somebody,
it's impossible for you to get
your head around that language.
And then they come home.  And
that language is still fresh in
their mind.  That's the language
they speak.
Yet, here they are on our
streets
trying to function as normal
citizens.
It's a very frustrating thing.
One friend of mine said how do
we transition somebody from
learning the
language of war and then going
to a civilian language once
again?  It's incumbent upon all
of us that these are people who
have given their who's for us.
They selflessly signed up and
served for country.  The least
we can do is pay them back.
When he said to me, why are you
doing this?  I said everybody
should.
There's 40,000 plus agencies,
non-profits out there, doing
things to help better the lives
of veterans.  In addition to
that, we have leaders
in our community, sitting off to
my left here, had they come back
and have suffering from PTSD.
All of them have scars.  Those
heal.  The wounds never heal.
The wounds stay with them
forever.  Some of them can adapt
and go back to life and try to
put it in their past,
and others make bad decisions
along the way and find
themselves in the courts,
as we discussed last year, and
maybe en
incarcerated.
These are people that went off
and fought for you.  Do you owe
them something?  Yes.  It's not
a hand out.  None of them would
take it.  A hand up is what
they're looking for just to get
back on their feet.
The panel, last year went a
little crazy.  We got a ten
minute dissertation.
I just want 60 seconds.  Please
introduce yourself and tell us
what you're doing in 60 seconds
and then we'll start the
conversation.
>> GREG CRAWFORD: I'm Greg
Crawford with the national
institute of corrections.  I
want to thank the Library of
Congress and Karen Lloyd for
bringing us back this year.  I
want to thank those who serve
our
country in uniform and those who
continue to serve whether you're
a law
enforcement officer or someone
working
in a veterans court, and also
the veteran peer mentors.
I served in the Air Force but it
did shape my life.  It helped
create structure and discipline
which was much needed.  Just ask
my father and mother at the
time.
It also led me into working in
the criminal justice system.
I worked three years in mental
health.  It shaped my philosophy
to working with people.  You
can't treat a piece of the
person.  You have to treat the
entire person.  That's why these
types of things, like
local housing
units for jails, work so
effectively.  You're treating
all the person.  Thank you James
Wright for the wonderful speech
and also Peter
Koutoujian and also Frank Lara.
And I want to thank the director
even though he couldn't be here.
Because without him we couldn't
be here today and issuing these
publication.  To thank you.
I alsoso thank you.
We started with -- we lost our
way.
This year we're releasing a
publication and I'm honored to
pass
it off to my colleague Bernard
Edelman who issued both of these
publications.
>> BERNARD EDELMAN: Let's see
if I can
do this in 59.  I'm from
Brooklyn.  Graduated from
college.  Got drafted.  Spent
most of 1970 in Vietnam.  That
changed my life.  It was not in
combat.
I was a correspondence
specialist.
I spent a lot of times in a
civil affairs unit.  Still
changed my life.  Came back, got
a career, certain things never
left me.
Participanted in a Vietnam art
show, brought it to New York
City, which is my hometown.
I was named by mayor Koch to
serve on the Vietnam memorial
commission.
We did the letters home from
Vietnam,
became an HBO documentary of the
same name.
Since then, I've became the
mayor's
office of veterans  affairs
director
under Ed, first public official
to put
his money where his mouth was
when it came to Vietnam
veterans.
I've been down here for 15 years
now with Vietnam Veterans of
America, which is one of the
most active of all the service
organizations.
I'm department
Deputy director for public
affairs.   Technically, though,
I'm a lobbiest.  Thank you.
>> MICHAEL JACKSON: My name is
Michael Jackson from the
Cleveland area, and I'm
a judge with Cuyahoga County
common pleas court.  I ran as a
veteran and I'm presently the
only veteran on our bench.  In
the Vietnam War after my college
graduation, I joined the Marine
Corps and was a first
lieutenant, commanding
a company, and a second
lieutenant commanding a platoon.
Came back, went to law school,
married the love of my life who
is here today.  And practiced
law and decided I wanted to be a
judge at the end of my career
and I wanted to start a veterans
treatment court.  Three years
ago we had one veteran and now
we have over 100 veterans in my
court.
We started a jail pod connecting
our
veterans court with those in the
county
jail and look forward to
exchanging some of those views
this afternoon.
>> MALIK MUHAMMAD: I'm Malik
Muhammad from Orange County
Florida.  I am retired military.
I retired in January of this
year.  The first six years of my
military career was spent on
active duty and the
remainder was as a reservist out
of Orlando, Florida.
I bring you greetings from
Orange County corrections
department.
>> RON PEREZ: I'm Ron Perez. I
too was drafted.
I'm a Vietnam veteran, drafted
shortly after high school,
served in Vietnam
from August 1st of 1967 to
August of 1968.
1975 I went into the San
Francisco county jail and have
been there ever since, working
for the sheriff's department in
their prison services division,
developing and creating
programs.  I retired from the
sheriff's
department approximately 2008,
shortly thereafter they
contacted me and said, Ron,
remember that veterans program
you said we should always start?
Well, we're going to do it.  So
I came back on a consulting
basis and the development and
implementation of the program.
We started our program in 2010.
2013, because we had showed we
had a significant population,
the veterans
court started, our program is
called COVER.  COVER stands for
community of veterans engaged
and restoration.
That name was the idea or brain
child
of our veterans service officer,
our sheriff at that time, loved
having programs like sheriff's
work alternative.  He loved
restored justice.
When he heard community of
veterans engaged in
restoration, he loved it.  Part
of the reason it was called
COVER, the officer from the
veterans service office was a
retired Air Force military and
you all know, if you were
in the military, you can't leave
your bullets without  bullet.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Good so you
haveTo have you all here.
Anybody here not familiar with
all the corrections system
works?  Good.  We don't have to
waste a lot of time.
My wife worked at the New York
Times dubbed the most violence
place for offenders in the free
world.  I was really happy when
she trotted out to work every
day.  It was an absolutely
horrible place.
Very well run and emac collate.
You would think it was a mall
when you drove by it.
But there were movements done
from certain sections of
populations.
They literally had to separate
the populations for fear of
violence.  They were all high
risk.
Anybody
So when they go into prison,
veterans, you would think it
would be a no-brainer to
segregate that population,
perhaps.
But why would they?  What about
the veterans population that
needs segregated?  That's put it
to the panel.  Why is it a good
idea to separate
veterans that find themselves
incarcerated?  Is there
something productive that will
come from that?  Is there a
chance you'll put them on the
path?  What is the reason for
that separation?  Anybody,
please?
>> I think the basic reason for
doing that is there's something
about being a veteran that's
different and separate from
those who have not served.  To
place veterans together you're
recreating a shared military
experience.  From my experience
it doesn't matter if the person
was in combat or not,
served early or served late, but
that
shared military experience other
veterans understand.
The veterans in our county jail
say the
same thing that all of the
veterans in the publication that
you'll have the
opportunity to read say in other
jails throughout the country, is
that it's safer.  It's quieter.
It's more peaceful.  They don't
fight.  If they do, they solve
it themselves.
And they respect each other in a
way that because they've all
served.  They may not like each
other, but they do respect each
other because of that service.
And they end up helping each
other in that regard.
For those who have drug
addictions or mental health
addictions or issues,
particularly PTSD, being in a
quiet safe place even if you
have to be there in jail is much
better than the general
population.
>> So I went on a few site
visita for this publication and
I want to add to what you said,
judge.  Another really good
thing for this the efficiency of
it.
One of the folks that mentioned
in Seattle was the fact that the
VA could come in, in one spot,
people could come into one spot
and talk to people, rather than
bounce around to different parts
of the correctional facility.
So I think efficiency this
having those resources all in
one spot makes a lot of sense.
>> It also helps your outside
agencies, also, and makes it
easy for them because they know
they just have to visit one
facility and they know they can
call and
check to make sure when they're
coming up to do the intake on
the veteran that the veteran is
there and not moved somewhere
else.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Have you
spent a lot
of time with the inmates in this
population?
Do you get the sense there
should have been some sort of
intervention?
What I found with those who came
back with PTSD, a lot of times
they just needed a friend.
A lot of times they feel
isolated and lost and nobody in
their family understands that
language they learned overseas
so they just shut down.  Is that
what you find.
>> We still have a significant
population of Vietnam  veterans
in our jail, and they say, this
is what I needed when I came
home from Vietnam.
If I had this, I would not have
spent so much time in the
criminal justice system.
>> MALIK MUHAMMAD: I've heard
similar things.  If these
programs were there when I got
out, maybe just maybe I wouldn't
have ended up in the criminal
justice system.
One of the things the military
taught us is comradedy.  You
place these guys in one
dedicated housing unit, you
start that treatment process for
recovery.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Let's talk
about resources.  Everyone is so
keenly aware that things cost
money.
I know the Middlesex sheriff was
talking about things they've
done.  This is just redirecting
as opposed to trying to acquire
more money or a budget to put
something together.  This isn't
something that could be cost
prohibitive?
>> RON PEREZ: For us in San
Francisco
we're extremely lucky because we
have
sheriffs that have focused on
this and we're able to tap into
already developed
programs and develop it for our
veterans.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: If you can
do it in San Francisco for
veterans, you can do this
anywhere.
>> RON PEREZ: That's correct.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: So maybe you
can
talk to some folks and redirect
assets
without putting more money on
the budget
da
more budgetary line?
>> MALIK MUHAMMAD: We did the
same
thing down in Orange County.
You can do this without spending
a lot of money.
>> The first thing you need to
do is find out your population.
Find out how many people you
have in custody.  Data will
drive a lot of decisions.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Judge, you
find that to be a good tool?
>> MICHAEL JACKSON: I'm a
veteran.  The sheriff is a
veteran.  The deputy sheriff in
charge of this is a veteran.
We both came to this idea at the
same time.  We started this
within 60 days after our first
meeting.
It's justing organizing the
jail.
And finding a spot that's
suitable in the confinement
facility.
Training your guards to deal
with veterans  differently.
Many who were veterans wanted to
participant in this project in
the county jail, because they
were veterans.  Some were upset
because they were doing that,
but by and large most of the
veterans wanted to be involved
because
they sensed that these veterans
with
some help would be taking the
first steps toward recovery.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: We'll talk
in a
second about the pitfalls you
might run into.  Maybe somebody
is watching live out
there with a jurisdiction and
they're thinking about it but
haven't done it.
But are they different?
You have some folks who are life
long criminals and these people
aren't going to be fixed or
cured of anything.  But when
veterans come in, do you get
the sense they just made a
mistake or take a bad decision?
Can they get put back on the
path quickly?
>> Veterans, because of the
facts that your jails and
prisons operate
semi-militaristic with
inspections, with
line-ups, et cetera, with work
detail.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Structure.
>> Structure. Exactly.
So veterans coming into the jail
system can fit very easily into
that system.  A lot of times,
what we've done before we
started our veterans programs,
the best workers in the jails
that were identified were often
veterans.
And veterans that would come
back into jail, oh, there's
Gunny.
He's going to run the kitchen.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: So they feel
like they're plugged in and have
a purpose.
>> RON PEREZ: Yep. They have
structure.
Go off to your work detail, come
back,
here is your phone call time,
your male
meal time, sleep time.
It's much easier than the
outside where they lost that
structure and lost that
comradery.
>> So reminding them of the
confidence they once had, I
think that's an important point
that this type of programming
does for veterans.  It gets
their sense of purpose back.  I
think that's what it does.  It
gets their confidence going.
>> It kind of reacclimates them
back to that military life
because that jails and prisons
are paramilitary organization.
It reacclimates them back to
what they were once comfortable
to.
It gives them a sense of pride
and leadership again, and also
you have that belongingness that
they oftentimes seek.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Any time we
send somebody into prison is
hope is that justice will be
served and they'll learn their
lesson and come back into
society.  Do you get a sense
from veterans when
they do make bad decisions and
get
themselves incarcerated, that
they are
able to that ac column mate to
public life by learning
something in prison?  Are they
successful candidates after
prison?  I don't know.  I'm
asking you.
>>
>> MICHAEL JACKSON: Well, in
many
prisons, especially in Ohio and
I think pretty much nationwide,
they've been
permitted to set up very similar
operations as we're talking
about with veterans in the
county jail.  If you go to a
number of prisons in
Ohio, you'll see veterans pods
there.
Some of them are even working
toward
doing productive businesses
while in prison.  That's
authorized.  And they have their
own discipline group among
themselves.
And they are transitioning to
the community by having people
come in.  In fact, one of the
veterans service
organizations, the AMVETS, even
have chapters of -- they're like
American legion, VFW, in
prisons.
So they're members of a veterans
organization.
It's not as if it doesn't go on
there.  Hopefully when they
transition out,
they'll have that foundation
that we can recreate and live
productive and law-abiding
lives.
The connection in the jails also
is worthy of note when you
connect with a veterans
treatment court.  So I will get
those people from the veterans
pod in the jail, put them in a
veterans treatment court
program, where they have four
stages they have to go through.
When they graduate, they have
the
ability, we hope, so be
self-sustaining.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: What kinds
of mistakes are some of these
veterans making when they come
back and they decide to make bad
decisions and find themselves
incarcerated?  We have the court
system that was set up which
tries to intervene and get in
between some of those veterans
coming
back that made minor infractions
in the world of criminal justice
system, but some of these are
very serious charges that they
may not see the light of day.
>> RON PEREZ: Sometimes it's as
simple
as not being in compliance with
their medication.  We had an
individual that came into
our system, was a captain, a
scholar, a West point graduate.
When he got out of the military,
he got himself a little plot of
land in
Alaska that butted up against
the forest, and everything was
fine except
when he came back to visit
family in the Bay area.  He got
himself into a situation where
he should have been dealt with
psychiatrickically, but instead
wound up being jailed.  He came
to our attention.
We weren't able to get him into
COVER because of his psychiatric
issues, but we were able to get
him into veterans court, get him
stabilized, and it was
determined through veterans
court the best thing to do would
be to get him back into this
community, back into Alaska
where he had veterans services
already in  place.
We were able to do that.
We had one of our veterans court
mentors fly back to Alaska with
him.
His veterans court status has
been
strains
veteran transitioned to Alaska.
He's still having difficulties,
but that was the best place for
him.  He should have never been
in the criminal justice system.
He should have been in the
mental health system.
But because of having COVER and
having veterans court, he's not
perfect, but he's stable and
living day-to-day.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Sheriff,
some of your examples?
>> MALIK MUHAMMAD: Just like
the technical violations he
mentioned,
sometimes I've seen them come
back for self-medicating.
Sometimes when times get toughed
when
they're released, they tend to
self-medicate and find
themselves back in custody for
something as minor as,
let's say, failing a drug test.
>> MICHAEL JACKSON: I think all
those
involved with helping veterans
while in jail all recognize that
there are a number of veterans
who draw some pretty serious
charges.  One of the things we
have to distinguish is holding
those -- that individual,
veteran or not, to be
accountable for their conduct.
The part that comes into play
that's effective for veterans is
that, to the extent we can, we
couple that with a treatment
situation.  So I just had a case
a couple weeks
ago where a veteran had a flash
back.
He was a combat veteran, Iraq,
had a flashback.
Three police officers were
injured.  None life threatening
to my knowledge.
The three officers were given
the opportunity at sentencing to
say what they wanted to happen
to this individual.  One said
prison.  One said, judge, it's
up to you.  The other said most
definitely probation.
The person who said probation
was a combat veteran.
And he understood what was going
on with
that veteran with regard to a
flashback.
And so as a treatment court
judge, I have to make that
decision with regard to being
accountable for that conduct,
which was serious, but also make
him available to the services
that I think would help him.
In his situation, he's going to
be confined for up to nine
months, maybe a little bit less
if he does well, but he's going
to be in the veterans treatment
court and in the veterans pod
and he's going to have access to
some treatment during this
process.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: One of the
biggest issues, especially with
those veterans
comes back in PTSD, is domestic
violence.  The numbers are just
astronomical.  It goes back to
the language I was discussing
earlier about the language of
war, when you come back, you
don't speak the same language.
The language in a relationship
is much different.  There's an
intimacy of a relationship of
understanding another person.
But those who have seen combat,
especially, and been affected by
war in such a meaningful way,
that shuts down in them.
Breaking through those
communication
lines, this is one of those
opportunities.
Unfortunately, it comes in
prison, which is what we're
talking about, in that setting.
I think it breaks everybody's
heart
hearing the fact that they have
to go to prison to find a
support group that ultimately
will help them on the road to
recovery.  Is that right?
>> MICHAEL JACKSON: Absolutely.
I talked to all 22 people in our
jail before I came out here.
All of them said essentially the
same thing that's in our
publication, they use this as a
support group among themselves.
They really are helping
themselves.
One of them told me, you know,
judge, a couple people were bad
rapping you.  One of them, he
said, he didn't think
the punishment was right, and
the other vet said, well, you
have four positive tests for
drug use.  What did you expect?
So they can have that
conversation.  And they can talk
it out.  And whether it's right
or wrong or
whether my punishment was too
hard or too lean, they have an
avenue of talking
it out among thens and they can
hear other sides.  That doesn't
generally go on in the
population, as I think many of
the sheriffs could attest better
than I.
>> RON PEREZ: I just wanted to
add.  You touched on domestic
violence.
Our program, we have a component
that the sheriff's department
had this
component quite some time ago,
"resolve
to stop the violence"
anti-domestic violence program.
It's been adapted actually by
the DA
and is being provided in San
Francisco to veterans and on the
outside it's called at Ease.  We
have a component in our COVER
program.
We call it Stand Down but it
talks and
deals with the man worldly
belief system and violence and
addressing that but it's geared
towards veterans.  I believe
it's probably the first one in
the country to be started
specifically for veterans
dealing with domestic  violence.
Again, that's something that the
VA, up until this point, has not
been looking at.
>> It strikes me that we feel
so good when folks come back
from a tour of
duty, whether it's Iraq,
Afghanistan,
Vietnam, greeted by their
family.  It's supposed to be
wonderful.  At least it is in
the opinion or the eyes of
people who see that.  There are
an awful lot of guys who come
back.  They ain't got no family.
The family is dysfunctional.
They've been  dysfunctional for
years.
The family were the brothers and
sisters they had in a combat
situation.
All of a sudden, they find
themselves without a support
group.  They start drinking or
drugging.
I know of one guy who was a crew
chief
on a Medacac, medical evacuation
helicopter
.  He would slosh through blood
every day when he was in the
air.  He came back.
Got married.  Couldn't talk to
his wife.
For ten years, he drank himself
into oblivion every night.
He started having flashbacks on
the way to work when he got a
different job.  His life is all
messed up.  Nobody told him he
had anything wrong with him.  He
knew something was the matter,
but he didn't know what it was.
It took him a long time before
there was an intervention and he
started getting help that he
needed.  A lot of that is
through the vet
centers, which is one of the
most successful operations of
the VA.
We often had to fight with the
VA to keep them.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: So talking
about, I
wish there was some way to
improve from active duty to the
VA services.  There was a gap.
I hate sometimes as a first
opportunity to intervene in
someone's life is involvement in
the justice system.  One of the
things, this publication focuses
on housing for local jails.
If you think about the continuum
of this, I think what's really
important, even though this
publication focuses on housing
units, it also
promoting collaboration among
entities within the criminal
justice system.
I think it's important to think
about as people are considering
implementing these programs is
partners with other parts of the
criminal justice system.
You cannot only share resources
but also improve outcomes.  If
law enforcement is talking to
the vet court, and that's
something I've
seen on the newest project the
working on around law
enforcement officers responding
to veterans in crisis.  We're
seeing a detective assigned to a
vet court.  There's this link
between the housing unit, the
vet court, and the community.  I
think judge Jackson has done a
good job of communicating
between the local jail and the
vet court and he's instrumental
to set that up.  I think that's
something important to think
about.
Not just focus on your own piece
but branching out and
communicating within your
system.
>> I think most who will hear
this will
say it's a great idea and a
no-brainer.  But why wouldn't
every correctional
house, whether a small
jurisdiction or a big unit, why
not institute this kind of
program and not do it right
away?
>> MALIK MUHAMMAD: I can't
think of a reason why they
wouldn't.  But I can answer as a
start-up.
The hardest part is the initial
buy-in.
Once you get those accomplished
or over those hurdles, it's
easier.
But I can't think of a reason
why we wouldn't look at helping
veterans.  I say that not just
because I'm a veteran but at
some point those men and women
in the units, they wore a
uniform and they decided at some
point they were
going to protect us and I think
for that we owe them.
>> Great point. If you're
running a vet court or a housing
unit, it's really important that
you track data.  That you
justify why this programming is
so important.
We all know anecdotally these
programs work and they're
effectively and they
reduce recidivism.
rebut if you're listening out
there, keep track of that data
so we can keep building?
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: How well
would
veterans do, let's say this
program didn't exist, nobody was
instituting it,
instituting stuck a veteran with
a minor infraction in a general
population unit, what happens to
them?
>> From what I've read and
discussed in interviews, they
get in general population and
they don't do well.  There's no
support system there.  They
don't want to fight with guys,
but other guys want to fight
with them.  You need to have
something where you
can depend on upon.  So you can
watch his six and he can watch
your six.
That doesn't happen in general
population.
>> RON PEREZ: If they come into
general population and they
don't receive any services,
they're going to leave without
any services and without any
direction and they're probably
going to be back very, very
shortly.  Where at least with a
program such as this, you're at
least making them aware what
services are available.  You're
making them aware of what
benefits they're eligible for,
because a
lot of times you'll find that
the veteran doesn't realize he's
eligible for any benefits,
especially if they have less
than an Honorable discharge.
They think there's nothing
available to them, when that's
not true.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Let's talk
about the pitfalls.
There's some jurisdictions out
there saying I'd love to do it,
but this is
going to be a hurdle.  Talk
about some issues that are in
the way and that you overcame
and how you did that.
>> RON PEREZ: The biggest thing
for us was probably getting
classifications on board.
Because obviously
Classifications is a big key
part of it because they
determine whether the individual
has any gang history, what his
sophistication is.
A lot of times that's how an
individual is housed.
If a veteran has some things in
his background, that could
exclude him from programming.
So if you have classifications
on board, they know it's a
veteran, you can look
at that veteran on a
case-by-case basis.
Why did you have these gang
ties?  Can you put those gang
ties off to the side?
Are you willing to participate
in treatment?  And for us in
California, now, they have
what's called milestones
credits.
Whether you're in county jail or
prison, for your participation,
in any treatment or any type of
programming, that's going to
give you time off your sentence.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Okay. Let's
quickly get some thoughts.
Sheriff?
>> MALIK MUHAMMAD: I was saying
just
getting some buy-in from the
staff.  Depending on the number
of veterans you have from your
organization, you get some push
back.  Some veterans actually
thought by establishing a
housing unit, that would
actually diminish their service.
Once they do training for  them,
they quickly realize there's
benefits in there by having the
program.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Judge?
>> MICHAEL JACKSON: I think
training the staff and making
sure they understand it is the
main thing.
And also convincing people
inside the jail and outside the
facility that these veterans are
not getting a break.  They're
being put together because,
one, there's less problems.
Less time they're going to spend
in confinement and reduced
privileges.
And you're going to have
necessary fewer guards involved
guarding these vets.
So there is an advantage that
can be assessed, that will be of
benefit to the
veterans, and to the jail
facility.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Bernard?
>> BERNARD EDELMAN: I think for
anybody who reads this
publication, a lot of those
answers will be found here.
What do you have to overcome?
What do you have to think about
when
you want to set up specialized
housing?
Call it whatever you want, but
what do you have to really
consider?
If you have  objections, how do
you overcome those objections?
Realistically, most of the
objections can be overcome by
just speaking
rationally and dealing with any
problems as they come up.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Greg?
>> GREG CRAWFORD: I want to
talk about the publication, as
well.  We want folks to read the
publication.  There are positive
examples of things happening
across the country.  These are
things for you to consider.  We
structured this around design,
development, implement, and
sustain.  There's examples from
each of these
folks, the king county in
Washington, in the Humvee
county, and in Middlesex county.
Each of the folks if you reached
out to them would be happy to
talk about it, but a lot of this
stuff is in here.
Contact me and we can have a
conversation.  Any of these
folks would be happy to help
you.  Thank you for joining us.
>> JONATHAN ELIAS: Anything
else before
we say good afternoon to you?
Any questions at all?  No
questions?
You did a great job of
explaining it all.  Thank you
guys for being  here, and thank
you guys for being here, as
well.
[Applause]
[End of event at 2:28 p.m.
CT.
]